[Musique]
lucas parmentier le premier volontaire
européen cueilli au département de la
réunion il a rejoint juin dernier
l'icône hotech historique de l'océan
indien pour une immersion de quatre mois
dans le cadre du projet de mise en
réseau des patrimoine iconographique de
l'océan indien
ce projet est financé par l'union
européenne au titre du feder et du
programme interreg 5 océan indien
ce programme dispose de son propre
dispositif de volontariat et c'est dans
ce cadre que rejoint que le cac a été
recrutée afin de contribuer et de faire
une immersion dans ce projet et dans le
réseau régional fuqua est venu en
renfort de l'équipe mais surtout il est
venu avec son regard neuf il est venu
avec son expérience de jeune avec ses
compétences techniques et avec une
volonté d'agir au service de la
solidarité régionale et bien sûr au
service d'un projet de conservation et
surtout de valorisation des images à
caractère historique
curieux et force de proposition lucas a
contribué à la valorisation de ce projet
alors j'ai fait
en réseau pour les connecter un jeu des
sept familles donc il reprend les règles
je regardais cette famille donc quand on
arrive sur la page on a les règles du
jeu voix la diction prix dont on crée sa
partie ont choisi son nom et on peut
jouer d'entraidé des ordinateurs voilà
donc on allait les petites cartes aux
joueurs butt 1
je demande le paysage de la famille
heureuse ans alors les fans ce sont les
sept pays ou région de l'océan indien
donc la réunion les comores les
seychelles madagascar maurice mayotte
nordiques et les membres de la famille y
en a quatre donc qu'elle soit un animal
sans visage sans un bâtiment sont un
portrait tous les cas si big djü pays
auquel il appartient voilà le nom plein
la vue est pas donc je pioche une carte
et je finis mon tour c'est extrêmement
enrichissant fins
quand les jeunes je trouve que ça
j'avais déjà des expériences
professionnelles
mais l'atout c'était vraiment de pouvoir
revoir tous ces corps de métiers à
l'action en même temps pour un jeune je
pense que c'est vraiment bien appris de
pouvoir vendre salon l'entretien l'envol
de dire oui bah j'ai déjà vu ça j'ai
déjà dû serge déjà vu ça ce dispositif
sera prochainement reconduits l'icône
hotech historique de l'océan indien
accueillera prochainement un nouveau
volontaire européen
[Musique]